-It's so nice to see you, buddy.
I can't even sit in this.
[ Laughter ]
I knew I'd make you laugh.
How are you, bud?
-I'm good. How are you?
-I'm fantastic.
Thank you so much for coming
back on "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate it.
I always love having you here.
I wanted to wear
something special for you
because I know you.
I know it's a big deal
to win three Michelin stars.
Because, I mean, this is --
it's a plant-based restaurant.
-You know, when I was a kid
and first started out cooking,
getting three Michelin stars
seemed like a dream
so big, like, scary,
scary to dream of.
It seemed unreachable.
And of course, 12 years ago,
eventually,
we reached that goal,
and it's such
a amazing honor,
and it's really meaningful
to the team and everyone.
But that we reached
this -- Michelin
has created the rules
for fine dining.
They've been around
for over 100 years,
and to reach that now
without using meat or fish
is something I never
thought was possible.
And it's sort of a marker that
there is change.
Like, with the restaurant,
we can create change.
-Yeah.
When did you get the idea
that you were going to switch
completely to plant-based?
-It was really
during the pandemic.
You know,
we turned the restaurant
into a community kitchen,
which you know. We started
feeding people in need.
And even though it was so scary
financially and we lost our team
and it was such a challenging
time for restaurants
and other businesses,
but I found
this whole new meaning.
Before that, it was
all about winning awards,
getting accolades,
and then during the pandemic,
it felt like,
wow, there is a higher purpose
and I felt more connected
with the language of food.
I felt more connected
with New York City.
And so when it was time
to reopen the restaurant,
it just was clear
that I didn't want
to open the same restaurant
as before.
And this is kind of
how this book came to be.
-Explain because "Eat More
Plants" is the name of the book,
and it is gorgeous, by the way.
-Thank you.
-By the way, I don't know
if you know this,
but it smells like crayons.
-I know. It's so nice. It does.
-It really does.
It is like -- But it's your
personal journal and painting.
-It was never
really meant to be a book,
but it was sort of like I've
been journaling my whole life
and I believe to speak things
into existence,
but even before I speak them
I sort of like meditate
on these ideas in my journals.
-Yeah.
-And during the pandemic,
it was really
sort of this meditation
on all kinds of vegetables
and sort of -- there was also
some thoughts in there
about reopening the restaurants.
-Yeah, there's a couple
of things in here
I was reading and I go,
"Oh, this is pretty personal,"
where you're like,
"Is this going to work?
Are people going to
come to this?"
-It is really personal.
And when I look at it now,
I remember those times
in the pandemic,
it was so scary.
And, you know, it's not
just an artistic endeavor,
but it's also a livelihood.
So, like,
we need guests to come.
And thankfully they have come.
But during the pandemic, I was
really laying awake at night
and didn't know what's going
to be next.
-If you had a future.
Well, how does this book --
how do you meet someone
that's going to put
this book out?
-So --
-Who did this?
-It was a friend of mine,
Roni Horn,
who is this amazing artist
who brought in her friend,
who is this publisher
in Germany
who creates some of
the most beautiful art books.
And they came into dinner
at Eleven Madison Park,
and he was so
taken by the experience.
And he asked about
the creative process.
And I was telling him
about my journal,
and then he said,
"Can I come see them?"
And I said, "Well,
they're not really,
you know, for people to see.
They're very personal."
But then, sure enough,
he showed up.
His name is Gerhard Steidl.
He's an icon
in the publishing world.
But he showed up
and he saw the journals,
and he said, "I would love
to do a book with you."
And that's how it came to be.
-It's gorgeous.
And it makes me happy.
And it makes me think
that there's
a future in this, buddy.
You're the greatest and always
doing something different.
-You make me laugh.
Thank you.
-Chef Daniel Humm, everybody.
"Eat More Plants"
is available now
at elevenmadisonhome.com.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.